for the former bank bosses this was a
lesson in humiliation
you made a really stupid bet
that went bad
didn't you
Senator and the taxpayers of America had
to pick up the tab
for your stupidity didn't they a
preliminary government report found both
Silicon Valley and signature Banks grew
too fast had too many uninsured accounts
and made risk Investments leading to
their spectacular failures the former
CEOs however declined to take blame do
you think that the poor management of
you and your staff contributed to the
failure of the bank I think the root
cause was the Panic that took place in a
few hours on so um you disagree you
think it was the right I think the bank
was the run on the bank I think do you
think it was the run on the bank that
caused the failure is that what you're
telling me the run on the bank at
Silicon Valley Bank customers withdrew
42 billion in just 10 hours that's more
than a million dollars per second the
government then took over and paid back
uninsured depositors to the tune of 20
billion dollars meanwhile CEO Greg
Becker was getting richer selling his
bank stock shortly before the crisis and
bringing his earnings for the past four
years to 40 million dollars how much of
the 40 million are you planning to
return how many times we go do this
dance Senator I promise to cooperate
with The Regulators can you play the
video for me signature bank's founder
Scott Shea was forced to watch this old
video of himself
[Music]
I happen to know for a fact that won't
happen Mr Shay you're in that video
aren't you
yes I'm in that video and you showed
that video to the public
um that video was designed as a morale
boosting but did you show up to the
public it was uh shown at the employee
parties but it was silicon Valley's
former Chief who went to Hawaii the day
after his bank failed that Drew the most
outrage did you have a chance to walk on
the beach sit on the beach and when you
did did you think about what you've done
to these people the last time that
silicon Valley's CEO testified before
Congress was to lobby for rolling back
banking regulations in 2018. he got what
he wanted and his bank grew as a result
now Congress is considering
re-tightening those rules but only after
putting those Bank bosses feet to the
fire
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera Washington